-My first guest
is a talented actress
who stars in the new movie,
"Our Friend,"
which is in theaters
and On Demand this Friday.
Here she is, Dakota Johnson!
Hi, Dakota!
-Hi.
-Thank you so much
for being on the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-You look great.
I haven't seen you in a while,
so we have a lot to catch up on.
First things first,
last March you gave a tour
to "Architectural Digest,"
and the Internet loved it.
I loved it, too.
It was just --
People were fascinated
with your green kitchen
and your love of limes.
-Yes.
-During the tour,
you very clearly state
that you love limes.
Take a look at this video.
-I love limes.
I love them.
-Yeah. Now what do you do
with all those limes?
-I actually didn't even know
that they were in there.
I was giving the tour
and went into the kitchen,
and it was set dressing.
I'm actually --
I'm allergic to limes.
-Oh, my --
Stop it, now.
-[ Chuckles ]
Yeah, I'm mildly allergic.
And honeydew melon, so another
green thing from the outside.
-You're good
with the honeydew melon.
-Oh, no, and the inside.
[ Both laugh ]
-You can't just --
No one eats the outside
of a honeydew melon.
-It's kind of beige,
and then the inside is green.
-Yes. Correct.
Yes.
I wouldn't eat the outside.
-It makes my tongue itch.
-But limes do the same thing?
-Um, kind of.
Limes make my tongue itch,
too, yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-That's so bizarre.
I mean, you had a lot of --
So, it was just set dressing,
and it looked pretty,
and then you were like,
"Yeah, I love limes."
You're just talking,
going with the flow.
-Yeah, because
it was hard to just ignore them,
so I just lied.
Just lied.
[ Both laugh ]
I went the full
opposite direction.
-Unbelievable.
I'm glad you came clean, man.
-[ Laughs ]
-I know that you've also been
working on projects.
Your production company,
TeaTime Pictures, I love that.
How's it going?
-TeaTime is going really well.
We are actually
gonna shoot our first movie
that we're producing,
starting February 1st.
And Tig Notaro, who you love,
and who I love...
-I love Tig!
-...and Stephanie Allynne --
they are married --
are directing together.
-No way!
Oh, I love them.
What's it called?
-We're in a very heated debate
about the title at the moment,
so it has no title.
[ Laughs ]
-"Lime Time"
or "Honeydew"?
-"Honeydew" is not bad.
I would watch that movie.
-I'd see "Honeydew."
Has nothing to do
with the movie.
-Yeah, no, I'd have
to read the script first.
But I'm sure Tig will --
She'll have a good title.
-Yeah, I'm excited.
It's gonna be fun and funny.
And it's, like,
really contained and short
and in L.A., and it'll be --
it'll be cool.
And then we make these lists
every month --
Well, now,
we used to do it weekly of,
like, top 10 lists
of what's the best to watch,
because I get --
I don't know about you,
but I get really overwhelmed
with kind of content overload
of like "What --
What am I supposed to watch
on all of the platforms
with all of the amazing shows?"
-There's too many good shows.
-We kind of comb through them.
-And then, I also heard that
you're into music playlists.
What do you make playlists for?
-Everything.
I make them for, like,
certain times of the year
or certain moods
or road trips or dinner parties.
-Yeah, dinner parties.
-Movies -- I do it a lot
for characters and things.
-Like, if you and I
were to go on a road trip,
what kind of music
would you put on for us?
-Well, what's the vibe
in our car?
-Fun, hittin' the road.
You're driving.
Um...
-I'm driving?
-I think so, yeah.
Do you want
to be passenger seat?
-Well, are we, like --
Is it, like, high energy?
Does it have an arc?
Does it go, like,
we start out, maybe we do --
Maybe it starts with
"By Your Side," by Sade,
because I'm sitting next to you,
by your side, in the car.
And then we're kind of groovin'.
And then, maybe it gets
really upbeat halfway through,
because we're bored,
and it's a road trip.
-I could see us --
-And then we get in a fight.
And then it goes
to, like, Philip Glass.
-Yep.
We get in a little tiff.
-Rolling hills.
-We get in a tiff.
But then we have
to go, like, to the restroom.
We get a snack,
get our blood sugar back up.
And then we make up again.
-Yeah, when we stop for a snack
and you go to the restroom,
then it's,
"Waiting on a Friend,"
by the Stones.
-I was thinking at one point,
do we sing
"Hit the Road, Jack"
and really get into it
and, like, fake lip-sync
and, like, laugh and stuff?
Wait.
Now I'm driving.
-Oh, yeah, well...
-Don't worry about it.
I'll drive.
-That's what the fight was,
because you're a back-seat
driver so then you take over.
'Cause I don't like fighting.
-No, I don't like fighting,
but, you know, I'm not even
a back-seat driver,
but it's either go with the GPS
or don't go with the GPS.
I can't be watching
you going like, "What?
What do you mean make a right?
I would never make a right."
I go, "Yeah, then turn it off."
Just go your way.
-Got it. Got it.
But if we go like --
♪ Hit the road, Jack,
and don't you come back ♪
-Where are we going?
-Then you go like...
♪ That's right ♪
It's like that.
And we start choreographing
a thing to it.
Maybe you have a kerchief.
-Probably, yeah,
'cause we're in a convertible.
-Now we're talking.
-Yeah.
-You know we're definitely
in a convertible.
-Where are we going?
-I think we're just touring,
like, those weird things that
you can see, like, on Route 66,
like, World's Biggest Ball
of Yarn, stuff like that.
-Okay, yeah.
-Just for like for some
Instagram photos to post.
-My kind of road.
-This sounds fun.
I like starting with Sade,
by the way, that's my jam.
"By Your Side."
That's my one.
-Great song.
-Oh, God, right now --
-I'll make you a playlist.
-You will?
-Yeah.
-I'd love one.
Hey, I want to talk about
your new movie.
-Okay.
-It's called "Our Friend."
-Yeah.
-It's based on a true story.
For anyone who doesn't know it,
can you set it up?
-Yes. It's based on a true story
of a couple who, the wife --
the woman has terminal cancer.
And their best friend moves in
and sort of takes care of them.
And throughout this, this story,
like tumbling over the years,
it's about, like,
immense friendship
and pain and torture
and, like, tragedy,
but also humor and levity
and love
and most of all just compassion.
-You do a great job
in the movie.
We even get to hear
you sing a little bit.
I don't think we've heard
you sing before, right?
How was that experience?
-No.
That was so scary.
I actually had -- I have a
little bit of stage fright.
Like, I --
When I come on your show,
I get really nervous,
and I laugh and then cry
most of the time.
-[ Laughs ]
You've cried.
Yeah, you've cried
a couple times, yes.
-I've cried a couple times,
which that's fine.
I'm used to it by now,
but singing in front of people
is actually
so terrifying for me.
And we had to shoot the scene
where you don't even
really see me, the camera's,
like, in the back of a --
like, you can't even really tell
what's going on,
and I was meant to be performing
in, like, community theater.
And they hit playback
of my voice --
my vocal recording
and called "action," and my --
it was like I had a panic attack
that manifested in all the ways
that it does, that it can,
so, like,
I just took off running.
Running, like around the
theater, around backstage.
I was running around,
and then just started
laughing hysterically,
and everyone on the crew's like,
"What's she doing?"
Running around, laughing,
and then just stopped moving
and started crying.
-Yeah.
Just complete --
Just embarrassment?
Or you spun yourself out?
-I just, like, got --
I don't know.
It took over.
I got so scared.
It was like extreme flight mode.
-Gosh.
For the scene --
Were you doing something
from a play, right?
Was it "Checkers" or something?
-Yes.
-That was the scene?
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, you know that really
famous musical, "Checkers"?
-Yeah, of course,
the famous musical, "Checkers."
But that was --
Ah, come on, that was so fun.
Well, you're great in it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dakota Johnson
in "Our Friend."
Take a look.
-I'd like to be blonde.
No, I, um...
I want to have blue hair.
[ Chuckles ]
And I also want
to go to New York one last time
and see "Les Mis."
And, um...
Mardi Gras.
I want to be a grand marshal.
And, um...
I want to sing on stage
with Katy Perry.
-Dakota Johnson.
"Our Friend" is in theaters
and On Demand this Friday.
When we come back,
Dakota is going to settle
some of the biggest debates
of all time.
Stick around.